ew you're gross that's fine I'm Turkish
actually I grew up in Turkey don't drop
me instead no you are absolutely a
typical sjw looking person tater tot
can't handle the [ __ ] heat Dude
where's this guy live
you know top G
ate have everyone on the Internet is
making content out of this man right now
so are we people are constantly want to
get on calls with them just to [ __ ] and
argue with them so this dude I've never
even heard of him until a week ago but
he's some super liberal dude who wanted
to take on the top G in an argument yeah
I mean there's a picture of Obama behind
him I kind of caught that liberal Vibe
right away okay let's see oh good we'll
just so good go into it with an open
minds who he has to say yeah Andrew I've
seen some of your work as you're doing
the rounds on Twitch here and uh a lot
of the things that you said that you've
been called out on specifically in
regards to like women driving as a
matter of fact are just generally untrue
there's no empirical evidence to back up
those claims which is why you resort to
anecdotes quite frequently and say
things like oh well it's just common
sense right but it's not technically
common sense it's just your personal
opinion completely it's my personal
opinion based on my personal biases of
my life experience in my experiences men
are better drivers than women I'm not
saying there's no good female drivers
I'm alsoing a female cat no no you're
misunderstanding what I'm saying there
is a truth and then there is your own
personal experiences backed by anecdotes
right or your own personal opinion
backed by anecdotes from your own
personal experiences now your own
personal experiences are oftentimes
going to be incorrect generally speaking
I would agree with Hassan in uh I'm I
prefer data over just you know opinion
but I've had the same experience as Tate
and I don't necessarily trust the New
York Times data that he put up because
any news outlet that has a political
lean to it is going to show data in a
certain a light and by an angle that
serves their narrative to be honest when
driving I personally don't see as much
of a correlation between like a certain
gender or race if I see a bad parking
job I kind of just think it's a stupid
person I don't necessarily like I don't
necessarily immediately think it's a
woman or something like that like it's
not fair to well it depends on like
somebody that can't parallel park I just
think that they're visiting the city
they're visiting the city they they
haven't powered a little part to the 10
years flying empirical evidence when
we're making decisions why because we
all carry a bunch of personal biases and
when we analyze situations we do not
have enough scope to grasp the entirety
of the situation we cannot comprehend it
with our human brains bro listen I
choose why when it comes to women
driving it's a funny point because the
truth is different the truth is the
exact opposite no no listen first things
first there's lies there's damn lies in
their statistics I'm sure you've heard
that from Mark Twain that's the first
thing the second thing is that you're
you're derived yeah you can massage
numbers but drive you're deriving your
truth from an internet study that's fine
you can derive your truth from in a
study on a bunch of different things
that's honestly another thing is that
how how can you really trust anything
you see on the internet when everything
that's portrayed to you is there's a
reason it's being portrayed to you that
way that's what I said you know the back
end reasoning for the person putting
that out I find it funny that he says
there's
I forget the words I used already that
there's you know so much more around our
understanding than we can understand yet
he won't acknowledge that he can't
understand that Tate's experience is
valid truth of life is the truth that
you experience as an individual that is
the only truth that we all live within
you live within your truths I live
within my truth because the truth I've
experienced as an individual it's you
certain things happen to you over and
over and over and over and over again
but the truth on the internet says it's
not true that doesn't mean that your
experiences are any less real 15. if you
come here and say the internet says X
but your experiences can be real you
could be a statistical anomaly as a
matter of fact I swear it's the same
during coven when all you'd see on the
media and stuff was how it was so bad
and I swear to God every single person I
talked to that had covet it just like
wasn't that bad for them and I was I
couldn't understand it I was like where
are all these people dying and stuff
like what's what's all this [ __ ] going
on like the whole country shut down over
like over what like my grandma just had
it and she was [ __ ] golfing like well
she had the vaccine so it helped her but
but truthfully less than one percent of
people died and they also admitted later
that somebody could walk in with a
gunshot die of The Gunshot but because
they had coveted I can't believe the
statistics they would list it as a
covert death it was ridiculous initially
it was all you get the vaccine you don't
have to wear a mask literally two months
later oh no actually everyone still
needs to wear the mask it's like then
what was the [ __ ] point of doing the
vaccine they just lie to you all the
time it's non-stop lies how can you
trust any data or anything these people
say it's all [ __ ] especially after
the age of covid and all the [ __ ]
truth we were told with that garbage you
want to sit here and say oh the internet
said X I'm sure the internet did I'm
talking about my personal experiences
and some people agree with me and some
people do not that is perfectly fine
don't give a [ __ ] if people agree with
me or otherwise people are listening to
me and they're either you know but
you're still wrong and that's the
problem I disagree with you do you want
to be right or do you want to keep
speaking into a hug box where people
agree with you
Actuarial science like an echo chamber I
would assume where you just kind of talk
to people who agree with you so you
continue to feel good about your points
but hug box that's that's like the most
woke term I've ever heard yet so far and
also who cares
yeah like I don't care if some guy's
like Bros can't drive I'm like okay
whatever like I I'm just gonna go get in
my car and drive I'm not gonna get mad
about it but even this guy is mad about
it everyone thought like you did right
we would have no scientific achievements
on this planet we would still be living
inside of [ __ ] caves as much as I
love liver King personally I don't think
that uh that would be a good planet to
live on I'm pretty happy for I don't
know all the medical achievements all
the scientific achievements that we have
reached there's also places where if you
just trusted all the data and the
government and everything the government
told you there's been some pretty
terrible [ __ ] that's happened
imagine you're living in in Germany and
you're just under the mindset where you
believe everything they tell you and
that Jews are the reason for your
economy being a failure oh
these people know what they're talking
about so true
yeah this guy his argument that like you
have to he's not even acknowledging that
you have to take in personal experience
to a certain extent because you have to
you can't you should honestly trust your
personal experience almost more than any
data that showed you because you know
that that's your truth if you're a
logical reasonable person who you take
both into account who doesn't have you
know bipolar schizophrenia you know a
psychopathy of some sort because those
people see things that the rest of us
don't so you got to be careful with a
statement like that because it's
freaking nuts who think that what
they're saying is right and all the
negative experience
we're at fault that is now you can sit
here and say the insurance claims say
that I never said the insurance claims
don't say that I'm saying that I am not
comfortable with women driving because
of my personal experience those are my
personal experiences you can drag up all
the empirical evidence in the world you
want to try and drag up anyone with a
brain knows how that aids the world
agendas anyway I don't want to go too
political on a stream that's going to
get taken down so I'm not saying that I
can't fight a female race car driver
driver I'm not saying that that's not
what I'm saying either I'm not talking
about I'm not talking about like uh
statistical anomalies I'm I'm straight
up talking about the overwhelming amount
of evidence that suggests that women are
more careful drivers than men okay and
therefore better drivers than men you
keep resorting back to uh your
personalizing yourself do you under so
let me walk this let me walk you through
this is do you agree that human beings
have biases
this kid is a fortnight player they're
both fortnite players
these are the these are the moderators I
used to play in tournaments against this
kid back in the day somebody needs to
step up and say guys you're repeating
yourselves this is getting boring let's
talk about another topic you know what's
crazy is that this girl got like so much
Fame out of being in this one podcast
that people are like already digging
through every social media post she's
ever had she's so pretty yeah she's
she's cute you believe that human beings
have biases
oh absolutely we're all biased okay
completely do you think that those
biases might Cloud your judgment
it's not about clouding jokes not just
your personal cloud not just your own
personal judgment do you think our
biases might Cloud our personal judgment
I think every single person on earth is
biased and lives within a bias
absolutely that's absolutely true if you
agree with me on both of those accounts
you understand that your anecdotes your
own personal accumulation of information
is going to be clouded by your own
personal biases so you're not going to
be able to assess the information
adequately in the same way that
empirical evidence would this is
precisely I do agree with him to an
extent
I do think intelligent people and sell
or not just intelligent self-aware
people can separate the two but I do
think that generally speaking people do
that they do let their personal biases
and their you know actual experience
affect affect their judgment to an
extreme that's a lot of how like racist
since I guess I don't even know do you
think racists become like like that
because of their personal biases or
because of stuff that they're fed it
could be any number of things a lot of
it a lot of it is the stories you hear
from when you're a little kid sitting at
the kitchen table listening to the
adults talk right up to your personal
biases right up to the experiences you
have yeah you know I mean what you see
on TV the type of media you're fed it
goes on and on so yeah there's so many
aspects of what forms somebody and then
there's nature versus nurture I can't I
can't stop looking at why this kid's
wearing a fortnight shirt well on a
podcast with entertain like what are you
doing bro he's a fortnight player man
that's his Jam don't be judging you or
that guy
I wasn't wearing fortnite shirts no you
weren't but you were the fortnite guy
why we look at data rather than make
arguments around our wait let me finish
come on I understand what you're saying
this is precisely why we do that
five times
you're saying that the empirical
evidence is saying X so it doesn't
matter what my personal experience is
that's fine my point is let me change it
let's say that the empirical evidence
says that Pitbull is more likely to bite
you than a Dalmatian but in your life
experience every time you went near a
Dalmatian it bit you and a pit bull
never did are you gonna go up to a
Dalmatian still completely and go oh
it's fine completely unbiased because
the empirical evidence says X when
you're covered in scars no you're gonna
say Dalmatians bite me for some reason
and I'm not comfortable around
Dalmatians that's called human nature so
I'm telling you my personal experiences
and I don't care I understand your point
empirical evidence says x women in this
country can do X I completely get that
the second is also cool country because
you're only talking about America
because you're American you don't see
outside of the world that's fine I'm
Turkish actually I grew up in turkey
that's not the point that's not the
point I'm making point I'm making is I'm
uncomfortable with a woman driving and
if you actually ask most women if it
gets late at night or it starts getting
dark or it starts raining heavily or the
parking gets difficult they usually ask
the man to drive themselves I know many
women who do that they're not offended
by my assign that's just true whenever
it's me and my friends with girls it's
always a guy driving like it's not it's
never really you don't even put the
woman in that position to drive unless
it's like her car and that's the only
way I have no problem being driven
around
not at all oh yeah you're gonna take
offense to it if a man wants to open a
door carry the heavy stuff drive me
around I'm all about it it's fine yeah
I'm tired you drive yeah how about it
and then I can have an extra you know
drink or whatever another Mega pint of
one like a mega to find a mega pint of
red wine you wrinkle the whole truck I
know loads of women go oh I don't want
to park you park it there's not a bad
thing about it who gives a [ __ ] right
it's not even a big deal you've come on
here deciding you really want to stick
up for the chicks and maybe you know one
of them will drive over to your house
we've got better things I don't think I
I look look let's be real I don't think
I need to be a male feminist to be able
to attract the women okay what is the
real point of being a male feminist then
if you're not just trying to get girls
do you really just do you really feel
like I really don't know what their
point is in today's times I think back
in the day when you know women
legitimately
couldn't legitimately had less rights
couldn't vote couldn't you know hold
certain positions things like that then
I get being like hey you know if you're
a father your daughter you're married to
an intelligent awesome woman you know
you could really feel those things but
today the male feminists are just
pissing and moaning about rights we
already have yeah and it's exhausting
listening to them and it's embarrassing
listen I I'm just I think they're all
emasculated I'm a male feminist what I
don't even like the female feminists or
the sexually gender ambiguous feminists
and not all of it modern feminism is
garbage you are creating now a
hypothetical scenario in which you want
your opponent to concede I can do the
exact same thing and say well in my
personal experience Dalmatians never
bite or pitbulls never bite whichever
one you thought was the more aggressive
breed right in my personal experience
check the pretty girl she's on her phone
she's like God this is boring but if in
a million times that I have bread pit
bulls or been around pitbulls not a
single one of them has ever been
aggressive we will never be able to
arrive at a meaningful solution or a
resolution to this conversation if we're
both operating on personal anecdotes and
hypotheticals that is not how you can
conduct an appropriate debate good so
now you're saying the thing I just said
that's exactly what he just said I might
have personally thought women are worse
at driving than men as well but once you
arrive at once you look at the evidence
and you realize that said evidence
suggests something else you're probably
not going to continue believing the
prior thing that you believed right we
went over the same point like five times
I know but it's just it's just weird
because I can't like I can't break
through uh Andrew's uh I understand your
point you're saying we're losing the
girl no no exactly
I'm sure you're double vaccinated it all
makes sense to me now
unless we're gonna sit here and talk
about empirical evidence that you found
on Google cool if you believe everything
that's on Google that is your
prerogative my friend if you think what
makes you sound smart in the modern
world after the three years we've just
been through to say that I read a piece
of paper that told me to believe X so I
believe X and I ignore my own personal
experiences I'm not asking you to ignore
your own personal experiences I'm simply
asking you to look at the data the New
York Times data stop it stop it you
can't take data from any extreme media
Outlet the media is out to get us and
this guy is I believe in data but I also
believe in if I read something on Fox
News I'm looking it up and finding other
sources that aren't necessarily
conservative sources to see the other
side I'm looking at CNN to see their
take on it and maybe somewhere in the
middle they can find the truth this guy
watches CNN reads the New York Times
it's so freaking clear he is so biased
that he can't even get out of his own
way to see another perspective Tate
lives entirely in his own head and is
just interested in his own experiences
and I and I think he's an intelligent
person and I think he's doing all right
I'd rather go with Tate's experiences
and great take and drive I don't want
this guy driving this shit's just boring
I'm yeah I'm driving if I get in the car
with this guy okay Andrew do you believe
well I didn't I didn't you didn't really
prove anything but it's cool uh do you
believe the Earth is flat or do you
believe the Earth is is spherical round
oh you took his headphones off he's very
stressed sometimes and you know yeah
yeah it's cool it's important you know
sometimes you can't take the heat
sometimes you can't take the heat you
gotta get out of the kitchen a little
bit I can't like I try to do that when
I'm smoking cigars to get the smoke
super white and clear like that I don't
know I gotta start smoking I'm in here
to practice no um Andrew do you believe
the Earth is flat around spherical Globe
do you believe it's around right but
when you walk outside it feels like it's
flat
it feels flat but you believe it's round
why do you believe the Earth is round
move on I'm gonna kill myself you go in
a [ __ ] airplane and you look out the
window and you can see the curvature
what kind of Point even is that
I have personal experience that would
prove to me that the worth is around oh
you have personal experience what
happened did you go up to the [ __ ]
moon is that how you figured it out
actually I flew up into space
that's crazy okay you don't have to Hey
listen you don't have to concede on that
point but I think you and I both
understand the importance of scientific
uh the importance of empirical evidence
in that one right or or you know science
and I thought wow this guy wow okay he's
gonna ruin the stream we had a hot chick
oh that was cute just chill out like
wait so what's up is it is a little bit
more difficult when I'm not like uh the
traditional like sjw looking person is
that why it it feels like the stream is
a little bit more ruined you are
absolutely a typical sjw looking person
yeah
you've got an Obama poster the long hair
the beat like beads come on bro like
there's nothing wrong with like like
you're looking like what do you want to
do he's a good looking dude but let's
not pretend that you're not as JW all
day oh yeah I could see you from a mile
away kid but dude you've been kicked in
the face and stuff like I'm sure you can
handle little old me exactly so I'll
tell you that's a professional
conversation we just had I said I am
biased and I don't believe women can
drive that's my personal experience I
don't care if anyone agrees who came
along you can't don't interrupt me you
came along and said no that's not true
because of the evidence I came and said
I don't care about it's my personal
experience you said I also have personal
experiences and we're all biased I agree
then you said even if I had you know
what also annoys me about these twitch
streams is that everyone thinks they're
so much tougher because they're behind
the screen and like so many people are
so much like so disrespectful which I
don't know each other though
I just think it's weird though because
if you're in person it's a totally
different game I would have been much
more tactful in our from the first video
when I quote unquote rated Tate if he
was sitting across from me at the table
I would have been much more yeah you
wouldn't have said who who [ __ ]
really you know what I just questioned
how he was raised yeah
I don't really talk like that face to
face so we're all guilty of it yeah we
can move on from that we can move on
from the the
importance of Science and and Andrew's
personal biases Andrew can you tell me a
little bit about uh the hustlers
University whatever that is not in a
promotional capacity I know that like
you're doing the rounds on Twitch and I
know that that's probably giving you a
big boost but I want to understand you
know because you are a businessman I
want to understand how you generate
Revenue uh is it okay to get this
information for free or do I have to pay
50 and then maybe get an affiliate link
and get other people to also join so I
can make a 10 cut off of them also
joining Hustler's University you can
find everything on the website and you
can join if you want more information
that's fine if you don't wanna you don't
want to share this information for free
right now you don't want to educate me
on that I don't want to sit here and
spend the next hour you trying to accuse
me of some [ __ ] I'm not I'm not I'm
here to learn Andrew you are a brilliant
mind that's what I'm talking about he's
just being a smart ass for no reason
yeah it's not cute adult maybe a little
rattled from the the numerous
concussions but brilliant nonetheless
want to hear more about your business
strategy if possible it's actually quite
interesting that people are too scared
to get in the ring try and make fun of
people who have very
all right so let's not let's not let's
not detract The Bravery of men who do
things you're afraid to do that's the
first thing no no you you are absolutely
incredibly Brave you still might have
CTE but you are incredibly Brave I I
appreciate it
no I'm literally but that's the truth
how is he even denying that he's being
sarcastic it's like painful to watch
he's being so sarcastic it's like he's a
teenage girl trapped in that body uh
Andrew I'd love to talk to you in more
detail if you'd like to I hope that one
day you can uh educate me on your your
Revenue strategies uh I mean it's it's
it does look a little bad though if
you're like if you feel as though I
should leave the call because you feel
like I'm overpowering you a little bit
you should stay on the call but I think
you should be more socially aware is
that a bad question hold on he just said
to Tate like uh
I should get off the car if you feel
then I'm overpowering you no you're just
getting on my nerves you're like a
goddamn nut ew you're gross thousands of
young men tell about your business
strategies I want to know more where's
this guy live okay I want you to be more
socially aware and understand you join
the screen everyone's begging for you to
leave The Vibes down it's boring you
know what my son I came here to have fun
you're being boring no one thinks you're
cool no things are intelligent don't
think you're funny I don't think I'm
cool or intelligent I just have
questions and you're not answering them
for some reason
science you're not the police he's not
invited for dinner ever
you don't get the pasta and the garbage
where's the freaking gabagoo no I am not
the UK police nor the Romanian one I'm
simply asking you questions about your
business strategy would you would you
literally educate people on I just want
to know how you [ __ ] how you do
growth and revenue why can't I be a
hustler I want to be a hustler like you
he could have gotten that he could have
gotten it if he just asked that question
instead of all that sarcastic [ __ ] like
or do I need to go get an affiliate link
and get 10 people to sign up and then
maybe I can pay 50 and get another thing
if he didn't say all that Tate might
have responded to him and said yeah I'll
tell you I don't even understand it is
he sitting on affiliate marketing now if
you do you know how many Place
businesses have affiliate codes he tried
to outsmart Tate by baiting him and
Tate's not taking anyone's bait okay I
know what he's trying to do he's trying
to call Hustlers University a pyramid
scheme but because it has an affiliate
program everything you know what an
affiliate program is everything has
affiliate programs they're just kind of
like being sarcastic I'm not I'm
literally not I promise I swear to Allah
xqc
yeah he should have hung up on that
[ __ ] way earlier than he did this one
excuse you what do you say my fault
excuse me
a million subscribers and there's people
all agreeing with him
like I get his side it's just I don't
like this dude at all I don't like the
way he expresses his points
I think he's obnoxious your little
comebacks no one's interested in them
okay it's okay Andrew if you want we can
have a we can have a conversation again
in the future occasional little English
accents my Bugatti
sparkling War
you've seen that clip right
no but but I don't like sparkling
you don't like sparkling water you don't
like water you put the bubbles
bubbles you're scared of bubbles you
little [ __ ] he's ridiculous this is why
I like I love Tate so much though is
because he's a genius with his marketing
strategy initially on his Tick Tock run
and when he took it over there was just
him saying ridiculous stuff like this
like sparkling water if you eat sushi
you're a [ __ ] I won't give CPR unless
you're a hot female and so everyone
watched those videos and they're like
what the [ __ ] this guy's saying the
craziest stuff and then he started
talking more sense and people were
listening to him and like oh wow this
dude's actually kind of spitting facts
we're depressed
all right peace boys have fun Andrew I'm
always open to talk to you my friend if
you'd like to what another conversation
how are you gonna [ __ ] talk so much
[ __ ] and then cry like a baby my man was
in his Fifi's on that one that was
Andrew Tate that's not good brother how
hard are they dick riding him on stream
right now let's hear oh man wasn't that
guy so [ __ ] boring right and then he
thinks he caught me somehow but really
he just killed the vibe I would have
loved to argue with him but he was so
boring
tater tot can't handle the [ __ ] heat
dude you didn't truly want to understand
all right you sounded like a teenage
girl who's like why didn't you call me
we're done with this with this yeah with
this Bumble Club oh [ __ ] that just
annoyed me
what do you give Hassan a reading one
one to ten on masculinity a two
on logic
before
all right guys uh as always I'm giving
away a hundred dollars to someone who
likes subscribes and then DMS me proof
on my Instagram
um we'll announce the winner next video
okay
all right guys